hello grammarians so i've talked about
the idea of verb tense which is the
ability to situate words in time but
today i'd like to talk about verb aspect
which is kind of like tense
but more so let me explain what that
means so with basic verb tense we can
distinguish between the present the
future and the past right so now
later
then right
past present and future
so i could say you know simply i
walk
i will walk
and
i walked
so this is the past this is the present
and this is the future
so that's that's verb tense but what's
really cool about verb aspect is it's
this tool that really allows us to
expand all the possible ways of
expressing something in time so you
could just say i walk true but you could
also say
i am walking or i'm walking
or you could say
i have walked
i have been
walking
all of these things are different
aspects they're different versions of
the verb to walk
in the present tense
and we'll explain all of those they'll
each get their own video but i just
wanted to impress upon you the idea that
within every tense past present and
future there are also four many tenses
or baby tenses and this is what we call
aspect and we'll get to the names of
those later don't worry about that now i
just wanted to just plant the seed
you can learn anything
dave it out